I have equipped you with a whole bunch
of trig identities right once you can
already use and that allows you to take
like a complicated thing and use all of
the tricks that in your tool belt so
sort of unravel oh okay
on top of all those trig identities you
should also know that always bring it
down you know if you've got tans or
Kosek or whatever all those combinations
whatever do is bring them down to in
terms of sine and cos and often things
were just kind of unfold from there okay
so those are perfectly fine in these two
cases which are the ones we've looked at
already right usually this is the most
common thing right one side messy one
side is simplified that's okay and all
you need to do is pick the appropriate
side and that's fine okay we looked at
this which was a bit more complicated if
both sides look awful and you work with
one side you get somewhere but then you
hit a brick wall okay well try working
on each side independently and then put
him in together case one case two but
this kind of implies a case three if
there's messy and simplified and then
messy and messy what do you think case 3
would be simplified and simplified right
now this is a problem this is a problem
and I'll write up an example for you in
a second okay well I'll write a foot
three now the reason this is a problem
is because our brains are not good at
adding complexity of something right
we're like what if this is as simple as
it's going to get and this is as simple
as it's gonna get what can I even do to
even show that these are equivalent so
let me give me an example of what I'm
talking about here we go this is case
three right you're asked to prove this
where do you even begin okay now I hope
that the way I phrased case one in case
to give you at least a bit of a clue as
to what I'm going to need to do with
this right case one you just simplify it
it's fun case two you simplify you
simplify again and then you put them
together you can't simply simply you
can't directly
by this right so if this is what you get
and these are some of the most
challenging times right what you need to
do your method is you need to make one
side message you need to break things
before you can fix them okay and this is
as simple as it's going to get you're
not going to get anywhere just sort of
like you're staring it down you have to
make it worse before it's gonna get
better okay now you can clearly see even
that both sides look simple simplified
one side is simpler than the other like
which one the right-hand side is clearly
simpler it's just a less terms okay so
therefore I think it will be easier for
me to go from here to here even if this
looks like it's fine more or less okay
so here's what I'm going to do left-hand
side let's write it out first sign up
okay
the reason why you can have two things
that look completely simplified
but they are not the same is because of
all this trig identities that are hiding
in the background okay
now this thing is trying to give you
clues it's trying to give you clues that
nudge you in the direction of what's the
most constructive way to break this
because believe me so I didn't just so
hard you can just go at them every
single angle and you get nowhere so
here's a helpful thing when I say make
one side message right what does that
even mean well generally it takes one of
two different forms either you add and
subtract the same term right off of one
of the sides right so it's like you add
sine squared and then you take away sine
squared so it doesn't look like anything
has changed but adding and subtracting
the same thing allows you to do some
kind of weed factorization so that's a
personable one add and subtract the same
thing the other approach well
addition subtraction you can do
multiplication if you multiply and
divide by the same thing that will often
be helpful and we've done this before
right if I gave you a question like this
one okay that looks as simple as it gets
right but it can be simplified further
because you can multiply and divide by
the same thing and it yields a useful
result okay so I'm gonna do the same
kind of thing here all that's left for
me to do is choose what to multiply mine
and divide so how about look at it for a
second I will give you some time to
think about this yourself before I spoil
it for you look at the configuration I
love on signs look at how the top and
bottom very very similar but just
slightly different what would you do
with this thing remember your end game
when you're trying to head I'll give you
a minute to think about first before I
show you what I did bit of a tip one of
the ways I said add subtract or multiply
divide another helpful way to break
things and make them look worse right is
by changing ones ones using the
regarding identity I recognize recognize
this okay now just saying I'm not gonna
do immediately right but I will do it
eventually right
so places that I see ones especially
when there are lots of other signs that
causes flying around that's kind of like
a something should be suspiciously okay
now the way I'm going to show you is not
the only way in fact I'm very open there
may well be a faster way to this but I
think this is kind of it is fairly
direct okay what do I see on the
denominator I try to give you a bit of a
clue yeah sine theta plus cos theta
minus one brains kind of fuzz out a
little bit when we don't see a prior in
your bantu trinomial but it is actually
a binomial in disguise okay and I could
take advantage of this just like I
showed you before we've done a rational
enough rational denominators and
rationalizing them I'm gonna multiply
this thing through by its conjugate
okay which looks like this sine theta
plus one okay
so key see you see they're conjugates
multiply divide
okay now you're winking at it a little
bit runners three terms three terms I'm
gonna end up with nine terms but you've
got to have a little bit of faith then
with all these signs and causes
multiplying by each other taking
advantage of this a whole lot of things
are gonna simplify out and also these
pluses and minuses which are alternating
should be doing the same thing okay
all right one by one let's have a look
at the numerator the denominator would
be easier once we'd be a possibility
right now so I'm gonna do sine theta
times all these guys then I'm going to
do minus cos theta times all these guys
etc on the denominator it is no it's not
because you need a minus sign here it's
not you could rearrange it I suppose you
could put a 1 over here
should we do that do we get that again
all right so in case you come this is
not how I did in my brain so this don't
goes badly for me I'm pretty much okay
sir alright that adds
plus 1 plus cos theta yes
very cool yes and to make it a little
more obvious on the numerator here I'll
just rearrange that that'll be plus 1
minus cos theta all right I haven't
changed that I just reordered a little
bit yeah okay so I've got a difference
of squares their difference is crazy all
right keep the guy
um difference of squares mean it's a
squared minus B squared so far so good
denominator a squared which is this guy
minus B squared done okay let's see if
let's see if it pans out okay sine
squared 2 sine theta yep
plus 1 so far so good - - close squared
all over take a breath same thing all
right I'm glad it worked some way to
sine theta cos theta
that's the 280 bit plus cos squared feet
up minus one okay what can I do here
what car
Oh No that's not gonna help okay sir up
here this die I can change that there's
something else I can change look at this
guy
here and here can you see that you see
what that's equal to all right so let's
give this a go that's gonna be sine
squared so how many sine Squared's what
I have on the numerator two of them two
sine squared theta plus two sine theta
that's looking promising isn't it can
you see it what are you gonna get on the
denominator by the way this this is a
crucial step when you do this when you
take advantage of this you must write it
you must absolutely right that it's
equal to one okay because you're using
identity and you're showing you know
what it is even if what you're gonna end
up having on the denominator will cancel
you have to show why it cancels first
okay all right factorize rise 2 sine
theta what am I gonna have sine theta
plus one right one all over once cancel
I've got my two sons already out the
front so you see yes it did get
considerably worse before it got better
but it did it did okay I like this
question in particular because if you
are in an exam and you're like panicking
panicking paging and you're like okay I
don't know what to do you don't see this
immediately so you just try you just try
working you know this approach that I
told you not to do right so immediately
the first thing you see it's like oh
these two fractions so you would you
would cross multiply right and you did
you know you work out something true but
it is absolutely not helpful at all it
gives you no insight into how do I
to solve it yeah yeah you ended up with
something I think it's even worse than
that right you're like oh great right so
I hope that make sense